[Music]
California's new governor faces backlash
from families of crime victims for
halting all executions President Trump
tweeted that Governor Gavin Newsom is
defying voters who want to keep the
death penalty supporters say the
governor is helping to end a barbaric
and racist practice that does not deter
crime
there are 737 inmates on death row in
California that is the most of any state
in the nation in 2012 and 2016 voters
rejected a measure to abolish capital
punishment aventure new governor Newsom
is here for his first live national TV
interview since his inauguration in
January welcome governor nice to be here
with you thank you for being here this
decision you said came from an emotional
place tell us what you mean by the where
the largest death row not only in
America but the largest in the Western
Hemisphere we've executed 13 people
since 1973 we've spent over 5 billion
dollars in costs associated with it just
last year we had someone who was
exonerated that spent 26 years on death
row joining the ranks of the hundred and
sixty-four human beings that have been
exonerated that have spent time on death
row it's a racist system you cannot deny
that there's no equal justice in the
system it's a system that is
perpetuating inequality it's a system
that I cannot in good conscience support
remember governors of the last back
straw you sign that death you literally
sign a piece of paper putting another
human being to death and if I executed
someone in California I'd be doing it
every day for the next two years so
answer that charge that this was put
before the voters of California in 2012
2016 they said they want the death
penalty and you by executive order have
essentially done something at odds with
the will of your voters and the voters
also entrusted me I have the right I
have the responsibility to advance my
judgment pursuant to the Constitution of
the state and I could provide reprieves
so I also have that right and that's
interested in me by the voters of
California and again this is not an
abstract issue any longer
we have 25 people that have already
cleared and ready to go they've gone
through all their appeals they've been
exhausted we're starting to stack folks
up I want to repeat what I said 737
people
you're gonna execute seven and thirty
seven people it's not only one a day for
two years it could be one a week for 14
years what kind of state what kind of
country does that and by the way that's
a worthy question to answer not just to
ask Saudi Arabia North Korea I mean
there are a few countries in the world
that still execute their citizens in a
premeditated way I don't think the
United States should be continued to be
in that let me ask you about another
topic and that's the environment you
were once called America's greenest
mayor what do you make of the Democrats
new proposal for the green New Deal is
there substance there is there something
to run on in this election yeah I mean
it's the California Dream Act we've been
on it for ten years there's nothing in
the green new deal at California is not
already advancing as our economy is
growing we are radically changing the
way we're producing and consuming energy
California is a leader in the movement
we're the only fully functioning
cap-and-trade program in the United
States and we're creating opportunities
and jobs innovation I love the spirit of
the green New Deal yeah the Republicans
are ripping it apart yeah they're making
stuff up it says as technologically
feasible I mean there's a trigger in the
entire piece of legislation that says
you know and it just it's it's
hyperbolic the fact is if you want any
evidence of climate change being real
come to California the hots are getting
hotter the wets are getting wetter the
dries are getting drier this historic
wildfires mudslides it is very real it's
very raw and in our state Democrats and
Republicans are saying you know what
enough enough we're not interested abate
we want to focus on what to do can we
talk about that college scandal because
two of your schools UCLA and USC where
parents were rigging the system getting
kids in when you heard that governor
what did you think and how were they
able to pull this off for so long you
know what I thought I thought it was
outrageous possible I serve on the UC
regents CSU Board of Trustees yeah but
then I immediately thought this what
about the legalized version of that what
about the folks riding the twenty
million dollar check putting their name
on that building why don't you connect
the dots to the folks that they quietly
called
for admissions or wrote a letter of
recommendation or family members that
got in and I think about how weighted
this is to people with wealth and
privilege not just the folks that are
now being indicted folks that are being
arrested so what's the answer what
I think there's a deep thought we've got
to reflect on this and in much deeper
way it's all about money it's all about
money
two-thirds of folks are in these
positions of influence as administrators
their purpose they're literally judged
on their basis of their connections and
their ability to raise money but with
that comes some expectation people
aren't just benignly riding a hundred
million dollar checks yeah they expect
something more than just their name
attached to it they're gonna get a
return phone call that to me is a more
insidious issue that we need to address
is that truth politicians that's deeply
true of politicians deeply - if anyone
in positions of influence and
politicians are among them but we see it
all the time as celebrities we see it
with people again with means they're
making calls to folks like me they don't
even need to make calls folks like me
because they've accessed the folks that
are making the real decisions within the
bureaucracies well governor Newsom I
know you're it's nice to have you here
in New York or in California let's go
back again honored thank you